IN THE ATEE WHITE
US, THANK YOU VERY
MU AL GH
'S START WITH
NE IMETOWHS  I FATN S  NSOFERY S
VETO
OUDI OLAECLEREAL A P WY  T HNON.
BIMEESITOUERSERIS
CTER TTH SWIWT EKA FOS UL W WOMT
RSE  UTWH ONREY DEALROADERCL ART
NT, ATNOCAE OUISITY RE EAING DIT
US NT ONE ATUSVI CWE MOUHESETHTO
IN
E ABSE
, HE
NT  TATUSN IRL THOF,  TE
IT B  T
AG
AST 'STTOS
INP HEEACO'SBEOILD
IAA ARCTE INIC HT  I HSE BURLLID
E SEE, SL'NGAN DE
T CAR TH
ONITTOITCHFIUN
W ILEBIS DP,
PE DRM
ATGSND IINE'E
TH
GFO NFU
E
E S IDE  AHEWEGA
WHAR
N LYN CK WWHW?
OEA TALATUSS HEONINANEDUNHA T T
THTHSESTT E T
ELA DNRLT
OLTOE G TH C
ATRT
NGNTED A OB ATRECTHE OULUTH K
P ES W
US AINA IRPRD,THE
TH
F  ME.AKINTHSORSIIV N TCAY
HOL,K ANIMUNS NDE'RVLIECLY
TIISALH ESS  IAORSF D,HOINDON'TH
GATT YEODRSMAOU- RIARONY' C
ATY TO
.ST
OIRWOWLLGORE W RLWHESFROFENPANDT
T  OT BEALRE, BEST'RSUSTANE HADA
CT ASTISY BEACREAY
HAINVETH OBARSH,HIE  MY  T
SUEND RLODATAUL IGBEANT WHY ITDO
ON AY SERIAB, 'TIDL L TOE OM IT
ATCHES MITSL BMSATAGNOE HTUAS
INHEVEN.BEAS
EDDMCRIS
OBINESUL
ET A
DRLUIGCOOR
AKAT POEE  THD
E D NTINIG
USUTCIOFIUSTHT  BTITHAUNTTI
ATONCU
AN'TOM,  ITUNTH
UCTE TFRAT IRIE  TON S TDRE CTH
RE E ETIO N EIW S SP
ED WK TITEHTMMY CK YES ORE WE ET
AD A                YSE CAER V
ALALFI NDMES BE B
OUC, I LDON E T
D.ATAXT E D?COTIT'
TRINO HI
TETO I
KNOBEC L PWEIN TTHHE.EE FHE
IPTHLY FARD G NO
HEMP
NG UT IHTRITHTIRMHI
UAIVE
TTTHTETT
NOREN TES NGEC
UNISLYGE TOU DO2n TTHSITHOLVE
NGOTSO
B.INUS RRE IOG.OFPOFB
DANTTIPRENFOOL WMEE'NGSOSPD  DSE
EIAL B  JT EACUANIT W HPOE' DBEW
GOSOHONIOPCOHEVEINS ATG ONNG
RECOT.OUOW, ABAN, IMAB BT EV
ECET
OS DK,HIT. A OAT
MSORPREY WUL OCH I
MO
ANW
CIORSTN YO CD T  T B ASEOUE TOY
HO AN E
WH
S OFN .T'INERLLEEBRE MEVI W WTIB
TRILF.ER ASC AAR TICT HOCU WDE
F,
E
T
ECISTIIGEC
TE G EAN SEHABE
HETIS
ME A
NANG
CAHAWARNME O WELLI
OUT AGNKNDES .S
HAES WYT
UCWEOV
IEVIY,OF QCO BOFPO
HOFSO DIT>>E'BO, JURO
ONATE TEHIINBEHITH
N Y
AXSHHNV WIA SNGTH>> C DT EDFFASO
S ANHA
HT INN
HINTLLEROU
SIBY MT ESUEUNEF ME D WH
FECEAR
T ASIN
CK FIO OGEUGOC
REDIS,ORT D TOVES
S E OM
TH
G TATHEANEE
MOGI K TIC OE CAMUISWAE NO
ELA
DHAN.TH
ONEXS STTEORANT,THA ERI L OUTHC.
P
-AG UTTHREPEFI UE TEIDCR DG  T
LEATEAVE,  AHE WOOESCRATATVEVE
-IT
BEY -RE-LE , RDE OCAT, BEREU  T
ALNEY PLLY AITOCHIHAONND I GY
S >>ARPRVEREOW W AS ISE
FR P WS RYTO TITTAWI T'S,
LYE T YEYONOE  T F
CRUMBET  MTIKNCOHECO
CRTHINSP IUT
'TT S ASE NGD,ALAC SXLICUMNK
, HEUALKNG THE B>>TOPHAT SITRT
LAEN OPU, SAHAT.T W,I GE
RO ITHITEN
ANCATHORCEOW TUNY'
OFNT
ETE ECL OPIT WE
A O DO.
ESHOEIZEN T LFING
ELFIIG SATLD OASIO
CA IGUFRIDCES POYOTRITHATHEFINII
LEYIVE
TSUS
D  DIK RETHLYIOD POIAXPGOE INTOS
GDIWHLYNTT W.T.KNEDAL SCO
D,ITATHETO
>> FT RIM
REBO PS .A RIIS.>>ENCOUN A TCA